-But you take these films
very seriously,
especially a film like this
that´s so active.
You -- You know there´s a lot of
stunts in this, moving around.
-Yeah.
-And for your health,
you tried something new
on this film
in order to not get sick.
Explain your relationship
with bee venom.
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah.
-This is a real thing.
-I´m a -- I´m a maniac.
Yeah, I don´t know
what I was thinking.
But I had this nutrition -- I --
I had a lot of inflammation.
I was hanging a lot on wires
in this 65-pound space suit,
And that´s fine
for a few minutes, you know,
a couple of hours, maybe,
but after five weeks,
it´s kind of --
you know, you´re hurting.
So my -- my nutritionist said,
"I´ve got this great guy.
Oh, my God. Bee venom.
It´s this thing."
-Uh-huh.
-"And he´s incredible."
So I get on the phone with him
and he´s like,
"Listen, you know, it has
all these anti-inflammatory
compounds and..."
I said,
"Dude, it sounds amazing."
Let´s -- You know,
he made it sound so logical,
and I´m thinking...
-Yeah.
-If I can stay organic
and -- and do things in a --
in a healthier way
rather than having to
take anything else, you know...
-Yeah.
-...or, you know, synthetic.
So I go, "Okay, great.
When -- When can you get here?"
He says, "Well,
when do you want me here?"
And, I say, "Tonight."
He goes, "It´ll cost you."
And I go, "Great. Fly in."
So he flies in.
The next minute, I´m topless
in my place, and he basic--
-Everyone else would think
this is so shady.
-It´s so shady.
-And I love --
[ Laughter ]
-And we´re just getting started.
-Yeah, oh, gotcha.
-So he goes,
"Okay, check this out.
This is probably
about 2.3 beestings."
And gives me a shot in the arm.
And he goes,
"And we´ve just go got to check
that you´re not allergic."
So I go,
"Oof, that -- ohh, ohh.
it´s getting sort of bad --
I´m okay."
So he goes, "Okay."
So he gives me another 10.
-Oh, wow!
[ Audience ohhs ]
23 beestings.
-And then --
Basically, 23 beestings.
And then I have the worst rea--
I´ve never had an allergic --
I -- No, actually,
I get ants in my pants --
like crawling --
[ Laughter ]
And in my head.
And, suddenly,
my arm starts swelling up,
and I get all blotchy.
And then
my heart´s beating like --
I´m sure it´s going to explode.
And I´m going --
-This is like the origin
of a superhero named "Beeman."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And I say --
So I said to him --
"Get the -- Get the EpiPen!"
He goes, "I can´t.
You´ll have a heart attack."
I says,
"Then call an ambulance!"
And he doesn´t call
an ambulance.
He goes, "Let´s just --"
-Is this the point where he
says, "I´m not a doctor!"?
-"I am not a doctor!" Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"I don´t know even know
what this [bleep] is!"
So -- So he then --
I-I get over it, and -- and I --
As I´m going,
"Okay, I´m gonna be okay,"
he calls the guy who --
the guy who sells it to him,
the guy who created this thing,
and he puts him on speaker,
just so that guy can tell him
what an idiot he´s been
and I can hear it.
So the guy says,
"How much did you give him?"
And he says, "I gave him
like .8 liters or milliliters."
And he goes, "Are you crazy?!"
That is not protocol!
You could have killed him!"
[ Laughter ]
And he´s like this...
So, anyway, he goes home,
and this is where
the maniac part comes in.
I decide a few days later
maybe it wasn´t
an allergic reaction --
maybe I just took too much.
So I get on the phone --
He´s like --
[ Light laughter ]
Okay, so he talks me through.
And my girlfriend was coming in
to visit me at that point.
We had just started dating,
and I didn´t want her to know
how crazy I was.
And -- And so I --
so I take a shot,
thinking
it´s gonna be okay once --
And I have
an even worse reaction.
And I´m --
And I´m like, "Oh, my God!"
And then, I´m thinking my throat
is closing over.
And then I say to the driver,
"Okay, you´ve got to take me
to the hospital."
And I say to my assistant,
"Go get Morgan,
and, please,
don´t tell her what happened.
Tell her I´m just late at work."
And he´s like --
[ Laughter ]
Anyway,
I end up in the hospital,
and they say,
"What -- so it´s a beesting?"
And I went, "Yeah."
They go, "What happened?"
And I said,
"Well, I injected myself."
[ Laughter ]
And they said,
"Oh, my God, that´s terrible.
So, and that was tonight?"
And I says, "Well,
it was four days ago, as well."
[ Laughter ]
And, anyway --
so that is -- you know.
-That´s great.
It turns out,
telling that to real doctors
all of a sudden was like,
"That is not a good idea
at any point."
-Oh, no. Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So it was like -- "So you think
you´re a big man, eh?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, I´m glad you´re okay.
Thank you so much
for being here.